researchers have discovered a way to
eliminate cavity-causing bacteria in
candy by covering it in more bacteria
and in order to prove that chemical
signals can transfer messages York
University researchers used vodka to
send the world's first chemical text
message Vsauce Kevin here this is mine
whoa
this Swiss bag safe full of money is
available to be purchased and then moved
and rebuilt anywhere in the world it's
the original bank safe from the
Schweitzer Volks Bank built in 1912
there are 1619 deposit boxes with
original keys and eight million pieces
of Swiss five cent coins which is 15
tons of liquid money a 75 year old
French man was given a revolutionary
heart transplant using a new artificial
heart the car mat is expected to operate
for as long as five years to give the
patient the ability to live a normal
life until a real heart can be donated
unlike artificial hearts used in the
past it was developed to fully replicate
the self-regulated contractions of a
real heart by using an intricate system
of sensors and micro processors that
monitors the body's internal changes and
alters the blood flow accordingly
brothers Simon and Chris Park are
launching their underwater jet pack the
arm worn propulsion system uses digital
monitors and wireless controls to
operate giving people a new way to
explore underwater Powe is a playful
interactive urinal concept that measures
your pee so yeah Metta Pro is an
augmented reality headset designed to
give you 15 times the screen area of
Google glass in a pair of aviator
glasses it mirrors devices such as
smartphones and laptops so users can
have them on the go at the touch of a
hologram for now there will be a cord
attached to a small computer that you
can fit in your pocket and they're ready
for pre-order at $3,000 in plan to ship
in July 2014 The Temper perfect mug is a
smart mug that allows the user to drink
hot beverages at the perfect temperature
all the time when the liquid inside is
too hot the wall of the mug takes out
the excess heat and then slowly releases
it back into the liquid as it cools
keeping it at the ideal drinking
temperature check out the Kickstarter
for more engineers a Pacific Northwest
National Laboratory have created a way
to turn algae into bio crude oil in less
than 60 minutes wet algae is pumped into
the front end of a chemical reactor when
the oil is produced in under an hour
the only byproducts are water and
material containing phosphorus which can
then be recycled to grow more algae
after production the oil can be convert
to be used as aviation fuel gasoline and
diesel fuel the chef robot is the winner
of the DARPA Robotics Challenge of 2013
they were given eight tasks to
demonstrate mobility dexterity
manipulation perception and operator
control and they were created to
simulate acts needed in a natural
disaster
these include operating a vehicle
navigating difficult terrain climbing a
ladder clearing debris door manipulation
removing an object from a wall
manipulating valves and operating a hose
researchers have developed a 3d modeling
system for babies with congenital heart
conditions since babies are unable to be
put into conventional 3d scanners like
MRIs doctors have relied on echo imaging
but now within five minutes they're able
to create a 3d image that they can share
and use to explain to parents and other
health workers finally Pleiades by
Japan's andr combines projected light
animation choreography and music
I'm gonna leave you with an autonomous
robotic dragonfly and as always thanks
for watching
you